what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel today I have a
special guest on the channel many know
him for his views on American women yes
very strong very very strong very strong
and very accurate views I'm not proud of
this reality but as long as you notice
that yeah yeah you want to introduce
yourself to the people Austin I'm Austin
Holloman what is accurate is that you
need to get your passport because it's a
step ahead yeah I felt a lot of like the
last day a ton of tons of massage when
you hear them yeah apparently yeah just
in the United States yeah I found out
something that I didn't know you've been
a Melanie King show yes so tell me about
that I had a video that went viral we're
at this place on a massaging hatred
actually let's start with the video so
she saw this video Yeah hatred towards
uh women in my culture which is not true
okay
um and it was so accurate
that she felt the need to say sir you
need to call in and I called in and I'm
not gonna lie I was very blunt because
I'm just fed up so I just give my
answers no we start comparing I can get
I can get pretty active but let's watch
the uh whichever one you want to do
we'll do we'll do this fine yeah I
didn't realize how long these are I
think we'll just do this one yeah
custom little emojis made all types of
fun stuff coming up so
um and I got someone in here
Austin
uh oh
it's a little glitchy for some reason
you look good in this little one but
okay it's a little bit better now hi
Austin hello
guys Austin you want to tell them about
yourself real quick
and why are you called in I'm Austin
Alderman I'm in Dallas Texas and I'm
here to influence men to stop dating the
United States all together and get your
passports because it's that bad out here
is that bad out here so guys somehow oh
there's a little Echo noise
uh let me see I may have to meet you in
between so guys all right so I stumbled
across this channel it was you know how
YouTube just recommends you channels and
I came across this content and I watched
a video by him but says I think it was
like 10 reasons or a certain number of
reasons why you should stop dating the
United States
so I found this interesting because
I hear this so much from different guys
I've recommended it to to certain guys
as well but I wanted to just have this
quick conversation I'm gonna take
callers tonight but I wanted to have
this quick conversation because I think
it'd be interesting or are you
distracted what were you distracted by
I was that's when my phone was blowing
up because I had just went viral so I
was getting all sorts of texts and
popping my neck you know I popped my
neck consistently for some reason so I
just looked hella distracted yeah it was
just an observation okay I think it'd be
interesting I think a lot of men have
heard these talking points like I'm not
paying attention I don't understand this
but I do not
most of us women understand
so it's like back to like like men don't
want to listen to women I was listening
but I just it just didn't look like it
23 right yes
now at 23 that's an early age to give up
[Laughter]
I mean I understand
um it's like interesting because I am
American you know
um however I grew up with like nannies
from around the world and I I could I
could understand why you guys would pick
them honestly yeah it's like you got
Instagram models in the US or you got
submissive Asian women or Brazilian
women I'm gonna tell you why it's an
early age to give up and why it's more
likely somebody my age to give up and I
want more men my age to give up
um
I am 23 so I grew up on the internet and
I grew up I was growing I was five when
my space was hot so women are displaying
their toxic behaviors and their
manipulation on Tick Tock and everything
and I'm more on the internet than a 43
year old so I see that and I experienced
a couple things I see other people
experience a couple of things I see
people in my family and then I get
online and then they're publicly saying
oh we're doing this dumb [ __ ] so it's
like oh let me try a different culture
and then I tried it I gave up on y'all
so what happened you went to Brazil for
like a vacation I went out there to meet
women it wasn't just the sightsee I
actually didn't do very much sightseeing
the first trip I got caught up in the
culture and the experience I was having
with the people but uh how long were you
there seven days and you were convinced
in that so I was convinced before how
many numbers did you get probably like
six six that was enough to convince you
well like I said I was convinced before
I got off the road okay because it's
that bad so what's like your worst
experience with a girl like what what's
the what's what's what's wrong and then
I can say okay which one I just want to
know what's driving you out of the
country like was there a Breaking Point
the breaking point was 2020 whenever I
was like damn I should be getting a
better result okay I should be getting
not that I couldn't get one but the
women I wanted it was either a game or
they didn't want me and then I went
overseas and it was like no the women I
want want me to okay okay so you felt
like you were getting rejected by women
that were below you no well I wouldn't
say above me either I know the women
that I wanted it wasn't it was like they
were protecting you it was so hard it
wouldn't be worth it it's like they
would make you jump through all these
too many Hoops yeah and you're just like
nah yeah I had to look like a complete
fool if I wanted them yeah okay and
you're like I just don't want you like I
don't I don't put up a [ __ ] like
there's dudes that have a strategy of oh
if she flakes do this you flake I'm not
doing [ __ ] if you don't have the common
courtesy to tell me you can't make it or
you change plans and you just leave me
in the dark yeah you're done but
overseas it's not a thing okay
completely on the U.S now I've heard
guys once they've gone through divorce
are there a certain age
um or they don't have any luck with
getting women here like it's just a
difficult situation for whatever reason
but I would think a guy like you
wouldn't have any issues
and I didn't mean to pause your computer
but I always wanted to say this
that's the problem with a lot of work
she doesn't know me so she's talking
about a guy like you she's talking about
my looks that doesn't mean anything I
mean looks get you looked at as a man
looks for a woman gets you everything
but uh modern women don't get that you
can be handsome but if you work at UPS
you don't have a chance over the guy
that's some big time millionaire that's
ugly as [ __ ] really that's interesting
because
I would think that like girls care about
looks more than like because you're a
barber that's a good job so like I don't
know why like I would still think like
you wouldn't have a problem looks made
her third he looks weird Okay and then
what do you think's the other two-thirds
the first one I would say is in today's
society's status so blue check marks and
all that you could be broke as hell and
have a blue check mark and you have a
better chance of the rich guy with no
notoriety I agree with that yeah that's
true the finances come second
then third is looks but you can't have
one and say you have the best I think
Lux is about I I think looks is above
let's break it down it's above what
money I think looks as a lot of money
but maybe that's that's probably just
because for me like it is but that's
probably because
I that's I've just never really had to
like worry about that so that's probably
why so yeah looks is number two and
what's number one no I think Lux is uh
I think status is above all I think
status yeah then Lex and then because
someone could look good but if he's
super awkward like it's like you know so
this dude has a blue check mark a
million subscribers and he's very
handsome yeah but he can't afford to
take you to flower child
for a date which is 30 dollars
where's the chance now
see that's what it looks no no okay okay
no
no ink like
for me okay that would be like but I
feel like most got like I'm just
thinking in the open dating Market if
you had to pick two I think those that
guy would be the more successful than
the guy with the other two in the open
dating Market in general but you know
what I'm saying like I think for like
American women like yeah in the open
dating Market you disagree I I'm I just
feel like like I've seen the ugliest
guys with check marks get hoes like last
time yeah so I'm like a check mark or
but then again but then but then again
like dude with a private jet isn't
having any issues either but and if he
has a jit he more than likely has a
status
and you had to have money to have yeah
okay okay okay yeah yeah you're probably
you're probably right you have to think
of somebody who's ugly as hell I'm rich
who I don't know no I'm thinking of um
the actor the Noah something the Jonah
Hill Jonah Hill girls aren't lining up
to date him he's got status he's got
he's got he's got he's got status and
money I don't think women are lining up
to date him
do you think he's short of anything when
it comes to him do you think he's short
looks he might not have the most women
out of all the celebrities but do you
think he's short like do you think do
you think he's having a lot of nights
where he doesn't have anybody to come
over no if he wants to yeah you know
what I don't want to eat by myself today
meet me over here baby you think he has
a problem probably not honestly I've
heard that women are more picky on looks
than men nowadays I feel like looks
might be well that wait so what would
you rate it so you raised why a lot of
women are single too yeah that's true
because they're being so picky on
everything yeah but are we about to ask
me no so I wanted to know would you
rated it you said status is second first
is first the status second Is wealth and
then third is look you have to have at
least two out of three to have success
yeah that's true if you have all three
you're unstoppable yeah that's true but
I mean well I would I would I would put
you would have to add a fourth one yeah
if you add a red pill knowledge you got
Unstoppable like that's like three right
but I don't think he's known for like a
being a player like he's known for
getting [ __ ] over from my
understanding right sort I mean he's
known for dating Lori Harvey I'm sure he
does fine I'm sure he's I mean yeah he's
not short but I don't think he's like
Redfield yeah I would put that as a game
but game is kind of part of social
status too because when I think of
status like I'm not even thinking of
like
a dude with a check mark I'm thinking of
a dude that's like charismatic so social
status yeah yeah I'd say like Charisma
goes with social status no no because
there's some bums on the couches very
charismatic yeah but that's what they
have they have status to me it's like
the same you think so yeah like that's
like I would rate it in the same
category like I think there's levels
right okay okay like I think there's
levels like a check mark is like the top
of it right but like I think that's how
the guys on the bum still get women as
they have social status they might not
have money but they have status and
looks
if there's a dude on my show
I don't even understand because he was
not cute but Batman yeah I'm gonna say
that social status and Charisma are not
the same they're different because last
night I said that a cop approached me
he's like he noticed me from YouTube
That's social status like oh that's
Austin so that was like a woman's
interest but I could still be boring as
hell when she when I go talk to her like
oh I don't know what to say and then
you're not that's not being charismatic
yeah I guess I see I'm thinking of them
as like interchangeable but I guess they
would be different like The Gift of Gab
is charismatic yeah but they had nothing
to do with status yeah that's true but
you can just buy a check mark nowadays I
need to buy one you can it's like it's
not hard all right I don't I don't care
so I've never done it but like you can I
could buy a check mark well I'm a single
man I care about a check mark I want to
be able to slide into the DM and it's
pretty much guaranteed
okay let's let's keep going with the
video seriously
what have been your what are your issues
you
say
very good at playing texting games
I don't do well with flakes
I don't do well with masculine women
I don't do well with women with bad
hygiene as well
okay so you think wait hold up wait wait
wait wait wait wait we're going back
we're gonna back it up and thank you for
my Super Chat nature Hill says we need
more black women like you I I appreciate
that I I do appreciate it guys every
time when you guys say that stuff like
that I don't know how to respond I'm
really weird with stuff like I am
socially awkward if y'all don't know
this but I am socially awkward so I
don't know how to respond but I
appreciate that because I don't want to
look like I'm putting down other women
or you know what I mean so anyway but
the hygiene part what's up with the
hygiene I wouldn't I wouldn't I would
hope you would have the answer
no I'm trying to what have you come
across that's been bad hygiene and
that's specific to the US and you're
saying women in other countries they
don't have these hygiene issues
in India that is not true you've ended
they nah I would agree I've heard of
Indians behaving I know their rivers are
dirty and all that kind of stuff
okay yeah
what are those issues
off pH
so is it like fish it smells like fish
yes
what are the ages of the women you're
doing
it makes it so much fun
I have been repeating those talking
points all week so I was like I was just
a fish
I smell like fish like it just makes
that you've dealt with in the U
.s more of that in the younger age
bracket but I mean there's no real
excuse for that you have access to the
internet I mean if I was a woman and I
smelled like that I would do something
about it
so but you would say across the board
how many times have you run into that
but enough that it turns you off from
U.S women
that's one reason
okay that's one
I just find that the funniest re I just
find that this like hilarious because I
think women need to hear it I I that's
why I'm trying to get like a a good
description of this for you you're
saying the hygiene is off they'll look
really good but they just not taking
care of themselves oh the teeth will be
white and everything yeah everything's
perfect on a db11 thank you hey boo dv11
hey YouTube wifey oh Lord keep up the
work we still got wedding plans to make
LOL
TV if you don't stop
you're a hot mess I don't know she just
friends I love my trucker I love my
truckers all right so yeah she
friendzoned him he sent her 100 bucks
right so
all right let's just take this one is
American one is what's your preferred
country to date in Brazil right now okay
so Brazil you know what's crazy where
what state do you live in Texas
okay I was gonna say I don't know how
many of you guys have actually come to
like Florida especially where I'm at in
Orlando Tampa I like all my neighbors
are Brazilian
uh or I mean it's just a huge
International place my daughters go to a
school with Brazilians Arabs Chinese
Korea like this is the biggest Melting
Pot and I've lived in New York this is
the most integrated Melting Pot I have
ever lived in and I absolutely love it
um so as a thing have there are pockets
of Brazilian women here in the U.S
yeah
go ahead
no go ahead
you don't want to associate with them
once they get back here
why why would you say that because
they're on the poison soil uh they can
fall victim to the culture and the
typical green cards switch up that
people say I think that's more so of
them adapting to U.S culture and not
coming over here with the antenna not
saying that doesn't happen but I just
think it's so much of if I moved to
Brazil eventually I would adapt some of
their characteristics and I think that's
what happened when women come here for
mothers did you hear how accurate that
statement was I just made yeah
yeah I had to break for a second okay
because I have had Brazilian guys reach
out to me and tell me the same thing
about their women there I've literally I
mean I can show you messages of guys and
I actually have no idea
those dudes aren't grateful they're
ungrateful like they they say they have
a red pill community in Brazil there's
no there's no need for it you know you
don't appreciate what you have until you
don't have it let those red pill
Brazilian dudes come stay in the states
for a month and you'll be [ __ ] blue
pill when you get back to Brazil
um I've heard in some countries like
it's they're still very hypergamous
since the beginning yeah but that's like
yeah but that's gonna happen no matter
what even in biblical days though yeah
yeah yeah you're right I had a Brazilian
Nanny she's great she's great she did
steal her credit card though so be
careful yeah
it'll be like with a smile on your face
though
hey it's worth it though yeah I mean
it's worth it I'm getting something out
of here do you have my credit card
you know I mean well in the United
States they steal your credit card you
don't get nothing out of it yeah just
like uh what was it Brittany Renner she
wanted her rent paid and yeah yeah what
was she gonna do for him nothing no no
that's the thing like I don't I
understand where you're coming from
because again I grew up with nannies and
I would say they're probably more
feminine and more and I'm sure most
Brazilian women aren't gonna steal your
credit cards no I was just thinking I
was like yeah that was that I did badly
no I don't shout out shout out Fernanda
you know I hope you're doing good maybe
I could
that
how old is she if she's too old if she
was your Nanny yeah well she's my nanny
when I was like 16 30. 30 or 35. yeah
they're all like 18 when they come oh
yeah up here in America it's like they
come for a year and they come it's like
usually they do it after high school
yeah when I was thinking nanny I was
thinking like a 40 year old no no no not
like you they're usually like they're
all in their 30s roughly now I would say
you know I did did really well in Brazil
because the guys are just like you need
to come to Brazil and do a tour and talk
to these women down here why do you
think they have a problem with the women
there but maybe American they don't have
a problem
huh they don't have a problem with the
women there I don't know but uh I have
heard Brazilian women say that there are
pH problems but I just haven't ran into
them and in the United States it's
normal no no not pH I mean problems with
the women with the attitudes the
entitlement that type of thing that's
what they will say
they say it's running rampant and then
and it's really really bad for them
used to it now let me go back to my
example if there was a woman
they twins one was here in the U.S pH
everything's good and the Brazilian
woman
why you would say the Brazilian woman
you would choose because she's less
masculine more what would you say
it's overall more feminine better
hygiene typically on average more
beautiful
that's true Brazilian girls are
beautiful they're stunning like yeah I I
think it's like because they had such a
mix of like cultures down there that
they just like yeah Brazilian girls are
stunning they have a mix of German uh
Italian Portuguese African yeah and
Native Americans and Japanese too
there's some Japanese Brazilians that
have the body of a Brazilian woman with
a Japanese face yeah yeah
really more beautiful okay so do you
think
that there's is there is there any
Redemption for us could American women
win you back or is it no no you're too
far gone you've already seen the light
is there any way you would ever date
back in the U.S no oh seriously do you
plan on moving to Brazil I'm on my way
out as soon as YouTube grows a little
more I'll be making these videos from
Brazil or somewhere else God this is
what women need to hear guys because now
we have I mean guys of all ages are
feeling this way about the US do you
think there's anything that could change
your mind about U.S women I'm not trying
to change your mind I'm just just
picking your brain right now so don't
think I'm trying to criticize or change
what he's doing
I'm just trying to get this information
out
uh the way house look and I don't really
see anything switching my mind
wow really okay so
um being down there in Brazil do you
plan on you're going to get married just
stay there long term because you say
bringing a woman back here she's going
to get out of pocket I plan to stay
there long term but I'm Gonna Keep
traveling to make sure that uh you'll be
back
I'm gonna predict this now okay this is
just on camera okay and I know this
because I'm an eight hour flight away
and it just becomes so damn inconvenient
to fly back and forth for every collab
every if you if you really blow up on
YouTube
he'll be back
he will be back he might bring a
Brazilian with him you know
yeah
well in five years I'm gonna say this
five years he'll be in the US just know
that if that is true which that does
sound like a very strong possibility it
was just for YouTube I didn't come back
I I agree I agree I really like London
now but I'll be back like it's too
inconvenient
it's like wait you want to take an
eight-hour flight three four times a
year
that's what I'm doing now okay I love
the airport yeah
first year it's like okay
second year
it's like okay you know that's why I
want to stay permanently I'm only 23 so
I don't want to permanently move there
yet but next year I'll be doing a lot of
traveling a lot more than I did this
year okay and have you had like an
American girlfriend before you have had
an American girlfriend how long ago was
that that was
it ended in 2020 February
uh oh I think you just you just froze in
me for a second can you hear me
it's a frozen straight face guys
I'm about to ask you some good questions
huh thank you for my uh Super Chat
George Tidwell I appreciate it and um
hey TJ keep pressing thank you guys I
appreciate that guys um shout out to my
moderators the harmony pill Jared
bargatty tonight I appreciate you guys
and um TJ if you guys don't know she is
a friend of Kevin's from high school and
college and she has a YouTube channel so
make sure you're checking her out
um so all right can you hear me
oh no he came back for a second it
glitched up again
is that me or you
what's up with your Wi-Fi the place I
was at my barber shop is in the old
neighborhood and I could have got fiber
but they wanted 300 bucks a month for
fiber and they kiss my ass a bit that's
ridiculous I'm not running an Apple
store I'm running a barber shop
yesterday so it might
oh oh yeah it's glitching shoot
you gotta do your phone sometimes
glitches I used to have bad Wi-Fi I
would like use my phone all right TJ I'm
I'm a I'm gonna pause for a second with
you and I'm gonna see I'm gonna talk to
somebody else and see if I can get you
back in here oh wait wait wait wait
it came up for a second all right guys
what what catapult it's pretty now it's
pretty all right so all right so 20 20
you guys broke up did you start after
that what what catapulted you to travel
to you know to travel and date after
that or did you do it before that
I didn't do it before that I I try to
date the entire 2020. uh it was all
right I mean I didn't have a problem
getting women but the women that I was
attracted to they seem to play a lot of
games like a lot of sabotaging games
and after a while that becomes pointless
and I knew I should have some sort of
better results so I I got that when I
went overseas
okay uh Kevin Marshall thank you for my
super chat it says U.S women got the box
what's that box that's the inside joke
from my channel oh okay we're like a uh
we like Curious George when we pop out
well he has a wind-up battery is what we
call it
okay okay all right no it's just because
she said it's like a Curious George when
you pop out I like that I know that all
right so after that you decided to
travel what convinced you to travel did
you go
uh I always knew I wanted to meet
Brazilian women and uh the American
women were pushing me away with all the
games and the extra stuff that made it
harder to just deal with them
so uh I started getting on YouTube and I
saw all the other dudes that do what I
do now and it pretty much sold me
okay all right and so your first trip to
was Brazil the first place you visited
yeah okay and have you visited other
countries
I am here soon but uh I can't announce
it because uh my critics are trying to
get me hurt when I go to the country so
really yeah can you announce it now
boy it was Columbia okay
okay I went to Columbia last week August
okay
uh
super preference you do a video over
that yeah
I still prefer Brazil
um why the beauty okay yeah they and I
know Portuguese oh okay and they were
more open to Americans okay so it's more
of like you were more of like a
commodity in Brazil yeah in Medellin and
they were used to it okay okay that's
not gonna stop me how are they trying to
stop you can't stop another person from
traveling and doing what they want to do
that they're trying to incite violence
on me
yeah
dude women or men yeah dudes
the same thing I have a lot of people
that make videos about me but I had one
dude and he said I was going to be dead
by 2023. oh wow yeah that's a lot well
he said whenever whenever I go to
Columbia I was going to be drugged and
robbed and killed yeah I don't even know
if I have a free time you just I kind of
what I've learned with the Internet is
people just say things like they don't
they don't mean it that was new today
though so I was just like whatever yeah
now they just they're just like behind a
keyboard they want to control you I hope
anyway you know what's funny I felt the
same thing I thought I would get a lot
of hate from women when I started my
channel I actually had the same as you I
had men that decided to hate on me
on this channel and I've really had no
real pushback from women or women coming
after me in any kind of way why are they
going after you
that's a good question I'm probably
jealous okay I kind of want to see this
the was that the most of it like the
funny parts yeah okay I kind of want to
see yeah
we're gonna be talking about what made
me leave two goats don't laugh
in other words what made me stop dating
in the United States
but I'm gonna break it down today okay
and these are in order I believe
from severity of why I stopped dating in
the United States
the number one thing okay I want to see
you
hey we're gonna say
this is before I started this is
actually a bunch I'm bringing down the
number one thing that stopped me from
dating the United States
was the texting games and the phone call
games the game
so we're not gonna act brand new we
noticed the thing here
you have to have some sort of game and
people get game confused with Charisma
those aren't the same thing okay
Charisma is the sweet talking and the
the emotional aspect of her getting to
like you with your words
but when I say game I'm talking about
I get your phone number now let me wait
two or three days to call you back like
if you know alpha male strategy he says
he waits 10 days to call a woman back
why the [ __ ] would I want to do that
okay I get it but then that's another
thing they say oh you got to pretend
like you have options you have to have
you have to show you have options don't
blow her up all the time text her in
between five minutes uh you know don't
I've said before don't have a routine uh
all that [ __ ]
you know all this you have to have this
super strategy just to get to know
somebody or even if you just want to
smash somebody it's usually not just
it's like it's like all these there's
someone behind the camera okay
it just looks like you're like like
pointing out and dating coaches coming
out that are just blowing up because
nobody can truly figure this [ __ ] out
right and if you're somebody like me
that's on their purpose I'm trying to
get my money right so I can live
overseas and get the hell out of here
I don't have time for the game look baby
either you want to [ __ ] with me you dope
and that's how my world works it's black
and white
there is no in between
either you want to [ __ ] with me or you
don't
and that's what when you go to to Brazil
see how accurate that is each number
you feel like that's all girls here
of course it's not all but it's an
overwhelming majority that you have to
it's just a game yeah well I feel like
you only have to play girl games with
girls that aren't that interested like I
feel like the girl really likes a guy
like you don't have to agree uh but the
thing is usually the chicks that are
like really interested you're not
interested in them like it's like ah
like uh this chick is like a four and
yeah she's the only one that's not
playing games but the seven or the eight
is playing games like she's a [ __ ]
11. yeah yeah I get you I get you okay I
can't do it so when I went to Brazil and
I saw those Texan games disappear
so the six numbers they all responded
immediately okay okay okay wouldn't give
you her number or she would give you her
number ninety percent of the time if she
gives you her number it's going
somewhere in United States how many did
you hook up with out of the six
uh I had a chick that was like my main
chicks there so on your week
yeah so well I was talking here before I
got it you already had a main chick
before I got there yeah we've been
talking for like five weeks so she she
didn't really let me how did you meet it
like on dating Instagram okay Instagram
she saw you she saw your videos no I've
had no this is before I started doing
the video back then oh okay I found her
account oh okay so you like followed her
she's like on your Explorer page
now I went looking for Brazilian women
oh okay okay typed in a bar scrolled
through oh that's I was just wondering
how you'd oh that's interesting that's a
strategy okay okay so her she was like
your main chick there and then she
didn't let me do anything oh so he was
just her too late I was two okay two for
six that's a good one out of three yeah
yeah she was holding me hostage so okay
are you gonna see her again when you go
back yeah
wow is she crazy well she was crazy but
that's not why I was over with uh
she didn't want to accept if she thought
she could accept me want to be single oh
okay now she wasn't so she wanted a
relationship but she only wasted three
months
okay well she wants to call it wasting
time she only wasted three months and
American chick will waste three years
you know what I'm talking about yeah I
[ __ ] off a lot of time and it's like why
did you try to keep going yeah it was
real it was in Brazil you know like okay
he's not on the same program yeah and
then she just moves on okay okay 90 of
the time you give a chick your number
it's not going anywhere then it makes
you wonder why
did you give me your number uh I've
mentioned in a tick tock video a chick
left a note on my cartoon chicks left a
note on my car
and then I call or text
and then I can't even hook up a date
with you or hook up a time to see you
why the [ __ ] did you leave a note on my
car
let me take a picture of his face I made
I gotta save that one
oh that's funny t-shirt face that's
funny I don't have time for that yo that
that's a bunch of that's like a bunch of
[ __ ] nobody has time for the Texan
games why would that happen though why
would a chick so you said the chicks
that play games are the ones that aren't
as interested but she left a note on my
car two cheeks live a note in my car
well how did Sir how did it go tell me
I'll tell you woman's point of view well
of course I got the note I didn't know
who it was from so I was like hey you
left this note send a picture uh-huh and
she sent a picture oh [ __ ] okay so uh
where are you at she's out of town and
then the texts were like five hours
apart each time so I was thinking oh
maybe she's at work but then when I
realized okay every Texas yeah we're
spaced out like what the [ __ ] are you
doing so I tried to call couldn't get on
the phone no okay look when you get back
let's do this oh you know you don't you
know uh yeah yeah I'll figure out
whenever I get back you left a note on
my [ __ ] car you can you [ __ ] with
me so what do you want
um she probably just wanted the
validation yeah absolutely yeah yeah she
probably just wanted the validation I
think I said that in this video is a
validation thing it's like the chicks
that choose like send shoes and signals
and you go approach and then they reject
you and you're like I know I wasn't
[ __ ] crazy like you just damned or
stuck your tongue out at me that you
don't look at everybody like that do you
and then I go over there and then you're
like why are you over here I'm like
what do you mean like what are you
talking about like you
you do not look at everybody like that
that was a hell of a look
and now you don't know why
or now you're shot that uh and then
they'll get on Tick Tock and complain
about how men don't approach them but
when they approach when they yeah yeah
it's just funny hearing this from a guy
uh
there is a high I don't care unless if
you're some sort of super rich man or
some celebrity there is a high flake
rate in the United States so we were
teenagers we knew this right now but I
had time for that when I was a teenager
like I didn't have a job or anything I
wasn't doing [ __ ] but going to school
and going home
when I went to the mall I had to get 10
numbers or if I went to Six Flags I had
to get 10 numbers why because out of 10
numbers only three of them [ __ ]
gonna text back I don't give a [ __ ] what
nobody says only three of those are
gonna text you back and I out of those
three two or maybe one or maybe two
you're gonna see again
it's it's just that
it's I don't care anybody tells you
otherwise it's full of [ __ ] unless if
there's some sort of celebrity but
they're not living the regular lifestyle
like this so as an adult
I knew that going to okay probably still
the same thing I still gotta uh approach
a lot of women but then it was just
coming back like damn the flake rate it
seemed like the flake rate has gotten
worse and I know some dumbass watching
this video right now is gonna be like
look in the mirror look in the mirror
that's not the [ __ ] problem because
this there's a abundance of men saying
the same thing and then you hear about
these women wanting to uh just have
validation in social media and cell
phones have created this where they have
access to so many but there is social
media in Brazil too and with dating apps
same problem they're they're 90 of those
women on dating apps are there for
validation like they're not there to
actually meet you when y'all match I can
tell you on one hand how many men women
I've met off of dating app which is at
the most three
I know for sure too but at the most
three and this is two years of being on
a day now
oh
three in two years yeah even even to
this day with the updated photos yeah
we'll see can I see your hinge or your
Tinder whatever it is oh no let me see I
want to see if
on Instagram
I've gotten okay many people that I've
met but uh but
you have to swipe right yeah
on date naps I have like the least I
have a uh I have to get rid of that one
why
in Brazil they love that photo
no it's like
I know this is gonna make me look bad if
I explain a lot oh here we go I know
it's about to say I'm bad it's that bad
yeah yeah no it's like I feel like like
selfies are kind of feminine and so yeah
so if like I see that guys taking like
selfies I'm like which I know is weird
because it's for a dating app but it's
like oh well I mean I can see why you
say it yeah
um let's see
yeah that would make me swipe left
immediately immediate love I've got see
I've gotten
that wasn't always on it yes it is
that's what it is
but it's so much it's so much
contradicting advice you don't know what
the hell yeah
because you'll see that and then
somebody else say no we want to see a
little more I mean this is also sexy
this is also tender so it's like I
deleted the other one
um
I just I just changed those that one's
that one's fine I think that's your best
one I think that should be your first
picture it was my first picture it
didn't make a difference
that I've shuffled these pictures around
and added and dropped new photos I get
the same result in the states
um
in Brazil I get a good result on dating
apps yeah that that one that one
what's your bio oh no bio I took it I
checked I tested that too I had a bio
in the states it didn't make a
difference I took out the bio same
result so I was like just leading
[ __ ] editor
Brazil yeah
it was in Brazil right
like I have 36 likes oh my God it is
[ __ ] disgusting wait can I see the
lights you get [ __ ] disgusting what
no it was a dude
but it was let me see that just oh yeah
this is another dude
it wasn't a good match it's too
Brazilian they all are oh they're all
Brazilian yeah oh no one's 36. that's
been in like maybe a day or two oh yeah
in the United States it probably took me
like a year to get that oh wow okay
likes with a boost I actually did a
video on YouTube where I boosted the
same photos the same tender profile I
boosted it in the United States in 30
minutes I got like it was less than 10
likes uh-huh
it was like seven likes I think I did
the same photos at the same time in
Brazil and I got 28 likes why is this
guy on here I don't Tinder needs to set
it where if you say you're in the uh
women they don't need to show men
your account
because I don't think I would have any
use if I yeah yeah if I was bisexual I
would have put that on there
and the other is like
just women that are matched and then
you'll get to hey okay let's meet this
day with the woo I try a lot of
different strategies I tried the sweet
talking then I tried to just go and try
it to the point neither one of them
works
a lot of these women are insecure they
have low self-esteem so they get on
these date naps
just to reject dudes they can feel it
man
I could get into that but they these
women they just get on this area
you get rejected half of more than half
of the time
your boyfriend like she told you it's
just for her ego they're just rejecting
you for validation for themselves
because they're insecure
uncertainty
so uncertainty is normal in every
country but in the United States it's a
lot more I think you like it because I'm
saying it's so cold
he is in uh Brazil in Brazil like I said
it's black and white it's a yes or no I
like you or I don't like you I want to
see you again I want to [ __ ] or I want
to be with your there's no in between
that's why when you go to these other
countries it seems like the women are
moving fast right but that's because
you're used to bullshitters you're used
to women in your own country that are
bullshitting you that are uncertain so
what's another example of uncertainty
you can here's two of them
there's a chick that I'm approached at
the gym and I've said this before and I
approached her at the gym
and clearly she has some sort of
interest because I I caught her you know
looking or whatever so I went up to
introduced myself and she's like how old
are you whenever they say that y'all
just walk off so uh she said how are you
I told her 23 she said 32 and she's like
oh well I have to think about it [ __ ]
I'm not gonna let you think about it I'm
like no I don't do thinking either
you're gonna decide now or not where
what
you think you got me on a leash or
something like I'm gonna come back and
double check hey just see it if you want
to talk to me now sorry baby you got the
wrong one and you're not even like
and that's the thing you're not even
top-notch enough to do that
uh another version of uncertainty that
the United States women have is
talking with you and this goes into the
validation talking with you
for an hour straight
I mean they might kiss you hug you y'all
out somewhere hanging out and let's say
you're not even trying to take them home
you say hey let me get your number
oh I only do Snapchat
guys you're not kids that's
disrespectful leave them alone count on
how many hands that chick gave you you
asking for a number she gave you her
social media instead count on one hand
how many of those women you actually met
it's probably Max One for me that's true
that's true if we're not interested
we'll just oh follow my Instagram yeah
you can follow mine or if I do follow
he's like okay I just had the intent of
following I don't I'm I'm taking it as
rejection yeah it is yeah it is thank
you for confirming that because there's
a lot of people no Americans they say oh
well we probably just need to get to
know each other before we give out
numbers like no that's [ __ ] if I
give you my Instagram it's like I'm just
trying to be and I know it's not nice
but like you should just say no I'm not
interested but it's it's we're just kind
of like we're women you know
like yeah that's true I don't know why
you talk to I I will not talk to a dude
for an hour I'm not attracted to it
happens no I've had a chick grab on my
nuts and everything
yeah she's like teasing me to the max
like blue balls teasing and then she
doesn't want to leave with me and I
can't get her number so I'm like why the
[ __ ] did you just do all that
and it is very good the only the only
thing I could think of is maybe like
there's been times where I'm talking to
okay okay because this is kind of how I
look at guys okay because I first of all
I gotta make sure he he no male feminist
I can't do that I can't yeah no nasty
NADA and it's funny because sometimes
guys will say stuff like that to me or
it's like Pro because I think my
personality people think I'm more left
like naturally if I'm like a die hard
because I don't even really think women
should vote like that's how conservative
I am wow
I go like arguably too far some would
say you know and so like I gotta sniff
that up so it's like I might be
attracted to a guy then we talk for like
half hour 40 minutes he says something
feminist oh no nasty NADA like just like
that and so different girls have
different things right so maybe it's
like you're talking to her for 30 40
minutes she's super into you and then
you just like like we're looking to
disqualify you guys are looking to
qualify thank you thank you for saying
it yeah you know it's true it's in
America they're looking for reasons to
disqualify yeah overseas they're looking
for reasons to promote yeah getting to
know you more yeah yeah yeah
I'm glad you know it yeah it's like
I can't male feminists I just can't I
can't anything left I can't do it no no
we're about to the the uh disqualifying
thing like they'd be like oh something
has to be wrong I'm like here we go
she's about to try to find something to
sabotage that's what I said sabotaging
games like oh yeah why are you single
I'm like oh here we go she's about to
try to find some something [ __ ] up
with me so she can cut me off and not
[ __ ] with me yeah that it it's
predictable yeah that these are program
responses like I said yeah yeah
something you're just so perfect I'm
like here we go something has to be
wrong I'm trying to think if I'm
I've thought that once but there was
something because I just felt like okay
this is gonna be very blunt I feel like
as men and women we start to kind of
know our league
yeah you know and so if a guy is like
interested in me and he's a little bit
like
annually yeah I'm like
you sabotaged it I don't sabotage it but
I'm like What's the in this case I was
kind of like what's the catch like there
and there was a catch yeah yeah
that was a big catch that was I was
right I was
and I know I know this man had kids he
didn't tell me yeah yeah so that was
that was like a big you know
[Laughter]
okay why you think kids I don't think
that's unreasonable to not do that I'm
just I'm just
yeah yeah I wouldn't it wasn't
I don't know I know girls will say they
don't care I'm not one of those girls I
will not do the children thing if she
says you know just give me uh I'm gonna
give you just my social media
I just take that as rejection because
that's Rejection it is rejection that's
not what you didn't get what you asked
for they rejected it and they gave you a
subpar product yeah okay here that's
fine and if she's really interested oh
I'm sorry because I mean there are some
weird dudes out there right but if she's
really interested in you or she see that
you know you declined taking her social
media she'll say okay well we're here to
take my number then you might know you
have somebody that may have dealt with a
stalker in the past but that's that's
just a cop out for him to say they had a
stalker if she likes you she's gonna
take the chance
without the phone women been getting
stalked for hundreds of years
number four
a lack of femininity so right now we
know we have women that are calling
dudes bro
we got women that are wearing boy
clothes
we got women that are uh that want to go
50 50 and wanna uh or they want to be
the leader of a household we got women
raising their voices at men like their
men but they only doing that because we
know we can't hit them because it's an
unfair fight that's why you shouldn't
hit women but uh but that those are all
I disagree equal rights equal lefts baby
I don't know I think if a girl slaps you
slap her back no no no no no no no no no
yeah if she slaps you yeah yeah that's
what what you get what comes with it but
oh yeah if she slaps you you get what
comes with it but yeah
but I'm just saying you shouldn't fight
women but if they hit you yeah they
start hitting like a dude your dude
that's how I feel like if I used to I
used to think never hit a woman I used
to think that until I started first I
until I started yeah first trying to hit
her back yeah but I started to see the
punches these girls would throw and I'm
like y'all are hitting like dudes you're
hitting like dudes get hit yeah I will
not
anyways oh masculine not they're not
feminine let me just say they're not
feminine traits right so when I went to
Brazil and when you see these women in
other countries you get the soft-spoken
uh the sweetness and either she's
calling you by her name but she's
calling you something sexy like baby or
daddy she's not gonna call you bro [ __ ]
I'm not your bro don't call me that [ __ ]
that [ __ ] gets on my nerves every chick
that has called me bro uh in the past
six months we don't talk anymore
I'm not your bro
you know I don't have sex with my Bros
stop calling me bro I'm not your bro
uh I didn't read that several times just
get rid of that word in general stop
calling me bro
you said I didn't mean to do that
number five insecure women so all this
almost all this ties in the insecure
women the texting games the flaking the
uncertainty they are not secure right so
if you're a guy that's doing pretty well
for yourself I'm 23 and I'm doing pretty
I'm way ahead of people my age and I
know that and I've experienced a lot to
know a lot of stuff
when women my age especially my age
whenever I run into them they're super
insecure like they think oh I'm not
ready for this guy
I think I'm better than nobody else
right but when you start acting like
you're not good enough for me now I'm
like okay well maybe I am too good for
her
like what's the reason why you know and
that's the thing why can't this is what
women understand we just want to be
sometimes not not sometimes most of the
time we just want a woman to be cool
with like and I'm not saying there's no
sex involved I'm saying but like just be
cool when I kind of approach you if you
accept and you want to talk to me just
relax talk wait
what do you mean like they say they're
not good enough
well it's just like the chick that says
uh
the one that's like oh well why there
has to be something wrong with you why
are you single or
why do you talk to me and it's like
because I'm attracted my eyes jumping
because I'm attracted don't look at it
uh because I'm gonna try it like why are
you talking to me but they're saying
that like what made you pick me and it's
oh no I I feel like I feel like it's
narcissism actually I don't think it's
like insecurity I think it's narcissism
they want to be special and they want
you to see like a specialness in them I
want you to revalidate yeah yeah I don't
I don't think it's insecurity I think
it's like narcissism
yeah anything about that yeah it's like
it's like
had this chart about dating modern women
it was so funny because he's like
they're all narcissistic they are and
he's like he's like yeah they want you
to be the perfect mix of mix of fun the
beta
beta but it'd be Alpha but they want you
to need you they want you to need them
that's beta
it is that's what it is yeah oh my gosh
actually I'm gonna show you I'm gonna
see how it goes all right so obviously
the Modern Woman is generally a
narcissist generally like they're
generally addicted to energy attention
and so the first step is to ignore Gus
like this woman right so you ignore her
because it shows your high value and you
guys like her by by kind of alternating
between the alpha she wants and the beta
feminism tells her she wants right so
you've got to be a badass but also
emotional and kind of vulnerable but
also ignore this woman or she will lose
interest
in other words show desperation and then
completely yes 24 hours it's kind of
cool being a Coquette it's a bunch of
things but generally if you fail at
stimulating the modern woman's limited
attention span you lose so you have to
kind of flip between the alpha because
they want they all want the top guy but
they want that top guy to need them
that's being [ __ ] so so you know if I
was if I was a six foot three athlete
with a six footer job why the [ __ ] would
I want you like are you that special
you're not but I have to convince you
you are right
why do you have to convince us that we
are because [ __ ] has infinite value
right you don't chase I chase you
because you're a queen you know that
anyway so Alpha Beta you Gaslight right
um You have to do at least these two and
flip between the alpha and beta step two
you get the contact details right so the
female has been uh properly stimulated
you're like uh you know let's Get Your
Number Instagram we'll hit you talk to
you whatever you have to keep this up
though step one never goes away
constantly you've got to do that when
you're married you've got to go to your
freaking coffin doing that right am I
gonna die who knows
that's sexy watch any movie the guy is
like I might pass away any time now he's
leaving notes and [ __ ] this dude just
doesn't want to die he's just [ __ ]
gaslighting her right so step two you
get the contacts and the emotionally
babysit so because of limited attention
she has these names right so by
emotionally babysitter I mean you've got
to kind of help her grow emotionally
she'd probably be hurt by some loser
um and you're gonna be one of those guys
but for now you've got to kind of throw
a trauma unpack all that stuff ask all
these cheesy questions no one really
cares about what was your last
relationship like do you value love uh
what kind of girl are you what kind of
guys she doesn't care what you like in
it so a lot of you guys in this stage
[ __ ] up because you're telling us stuff
about you she doesn't care I've never
heard a woman be like I met this guy and
it's really interested in architecture
she doesn't care about she doesn't care
all she heard was your job title and she
saw how you looked in your General
Physics
that's it listen bro so you drive
exactly so emotionally babysit this
period takes one to three weeks because
obviously you know you can't answer too
frequently you've got to give a Time the
gaslighting and the ignoring is
important got to make it feel like you
might ignore the text
um never reach too far you know make
statements don't ask questions or too
many questions and if you do ask a
question make sure it's something she
obviously wants to talk about like how
sexy she is her value in a long-term
leadership all that kind of [ __ ] that
actually doesn't mean anything much she
probably tells herself that every night
so you do that one to three weeks has
passed now you're going for the kill
right
invite her on maximum few days this is
my role you guys you Sims can do 100 if
you want but I do three dates date one
cold close because you're still
gaslighting this [ __ ] right how could
you let her know you kind of want to
shagger don't don't know that don't give
you that power she's gonna get gas so
you guys like her you know you're still
kind of flipping between Alpha Beta
second day you gotta close because you
know we all got jobs and stuff we've got
stuff to do right so we try and close if
that fails you go back to step one and
repeat
if that succeeds
I've got this page right so now
what you do is it lasts for about four
weeks you know and now you're kind of
just you know texting and hooking up
generally
um but you've got to tease long-term
relationship at some point because you
know does this go viral yeah it should
have yeah accurate
I'm just trying to yeah so far yeah no
it's it's but this is what I refuse to
do I refuse to the first part is so
accurate this [ __ ] is ridiculous you
have to ignore and Gaslight and then
yeah it's that's too much you can't have
you can't have a purpose in life and be
able to master this [ __ ] as a man like
you can't be some business owner that
does all this and then that's the whole
that's a whole second business he works
in banking I don't know that's the
second business yeah
apparently no I just moved to Brazil and
you move to Brazil this list turns into
like one it's it's different it's just
well I'm trying to keep it going as long
as possible so it lost about four weeks
and then she's kind of I've noticed this
kind of lines it links up with the
menstrual cycle
the next Marshall cycle she's gonna be
like do I need this guy
after about a month thing's gonna get
shaky you tease long-term relationship
oh you know
what do you want I'm not sure yet I know
what I [ __ ] want hey I wanted to Shag
this whole time in a month I'm gonna
want a shag it doesn't change
well you tease that yeah yeah and you
don't have to do it too hard don't try
too hard just say stay less less is more
right because then she'll just you know
she'll figure out herself you know
she'll she'll think what she wants to
think and then you repeat but generally
you know everyone has a shelf life she
normally kind of
the Smart Ones tend to kind of fade away
quicker
um but some of the Smart Ones last
longer those are the best but um
step four as you guys so when you end a
relationship with the modern women
because they're narcissists you really
don't want to give her any ammunition
because she will [ __ ] about you to
everyone so what you've got to do is you
just go cold turkey you just stop if you
explain what she will tell people is the
things you just told her explain which
is going to be [ __ ] because we all
just want to [ __ ] so she's gonna tell
other people that and then there's gonna
be rumors and there's gonna be all this
energy I don't want to give you that
ammunition so
I'll just go to yeah I'll just like just
why why explain anything is she gonna
listen to you or not like I get that I
wouldn't be with me either she's not so
what's the point is she gonna take your
critique absolutely not she's probably a
modern woman she can do it too she's
probably gonna tell you that like you're
some [ __ ] you're abusive or
manipulative or some kind of gas like
what kind of work that's like about
listen you can't do it it's modern times
um so that's generally the
infrastructure
um it's a lot more complicated than this
class any questions uh um I could tell
my ex by ghost in here what I kicked out
my ex by ghost in her oh really yeah it
wasn't even like uh what see she tried
to manipulate me by we were on a
so-called breakout because she was being
very just unappreciative so I was like
go back to your mom's house for a week
and so you can just notice a difference
and she was going maybe a day or two and
then she came back when I uh while I was
gone she had moved all her stuff out so
I was like oh well that [ __ ] is
gone and then I blocked her number I
blocked her whole family and um
she called my client that I cut his hair
she called him
and said Austin's broke up with me he
won't answer the phone or nothing and oh
yeah
I just I never reached out I just said
tell her that you talk to me but just
say that and yeah he knows you left did
you ever hear from her again
you ever talked to her again I reached
out to her like 18 months later
oh okay
it did it worked a few times uh but
still the same person so I was like I
don't know
we'd never get back together and then I
ended up having to block her again
this is an interesting conversation
about modern dating I feel like I've
learned a lot
let's see why you're moving yeah
yeah especially with that guy in his
chart yeah yeah their chart is accurate
yeah that's what it takes yeah that was
a funny issue it might not be for you
but for the majority of women out here
that [ __ ] that he under charges with
yeah yeah no I could see it
yeah yeah I could yeah I understand why
you're leaving though I wish you luck
thanks obviously you don't need it in
Brazil but I appreciate it
um tell the people where they can find
you Austin Holloman is
a-u-s-t-o-n-h-o-l-l-e-m-a-n if you want
to watch videos
in Brazil on boots on the ground
interviews with the women there to
confirm what I'm talking about because a
lot of people may think I'm just making
it up or it's too good to be true I'm
gonna actually have the women tell you
I've already done it but I'm gonna do it
in person this time go follow his
channel
um he's pretty funny actually with
things yeah with the he's pretty funny
on the panel we did the other day you
guys should watch that too on purple
pill podcast
um don't forget to like the video on
your way out subscribe to the channel
and bring that notification Bell and
I'll talk to you next time as many of
you know I was just banned on Tick Tock
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible